I'd said a last class session that we
were pretty much finished with with
Catholicism in the grand can't history
of American culture but that's not
entirely true because the last chapter
that actually deals with it is this this
chapter on the religion of Spanish
speaking peoples and why did they why
did they separate them out from other
ethnicities who were closely connected
with Catholicism what was the point of
that just to follow along census lines
you know mostly the ethnicities
associated with Roman Catholics are
counted as white according to the US
census and then we have as category
Hispanic Latino and I changes names
every so often it is that why they did
it or is there is there a different
better academic reason for putting it a
lot to a different chapter give some
some of you know justification of this
he also talks about the problem with
even speaking of hispanic or latino in
terms of ethnicity whatever some of the
problems with that we've talked about
this before in other classes with the
weird ways in which we define race or
ethnicity here in the united states so
that you know people as as disparate as
for example people from the Middle East
get lumped under white and then if you
just move a little bit further east
you'll be in this gigantic category of
Asian technically South Asian even
though they may look a lot live a lot
you know
a lot in common with each other we are
these really strange dividing lines why
is this support particularly a problem
for hispanic or latino designations ya
can't love them to one color but the
same time they're not almost very
strange yeah yeah there there's a big
question about whether they should be
considered a separate category sometimes
you know well Latino you know Latin the
seven languages why not include the
french-canadian seven Niner chicken suit
yeah there there's a lot of weird big
things of this and then you know
immigration has produced these centers
where there are Hispanics who don't
speak Spanish at all so if you're going
to find it in terms of language you know
that makes it a little bit questionable
you're right there's you can't
associated with race because there's a
mixture of European ancestry African
ancestry Native American ancestry and
the Native American ancestry made very
considerably depending on what area
we're talking about you know it's not as
if Incans from say Peru have exactly the
same genes as Navajos there's a lot of
genetic diversity as well you're mainly
diss tracks about three areas and why do
they concentrate on those well because
the bulk of immigration to the United
States of spanish-speaking people has
come either from Mexico or berto Rico or
from Cuba but what are some of the other
important areas that we could have
included if they wanted to make this
chapter more comprehensive yeah
that's a surprised not to see that in
here is enough but they're very
different right you know you call it
call it Dominican of Puerto Rico and
that's not going to go over too well or
vice versa who else so that's a
Caribbean country for like 40 but yeah
other South American countries a lot of
these informations not just for Mexico
much about South America yep like Panama
a lot of military spouses and
immigration from Panama so you know
could could what they're saying here be
generalized to include all these other
people's you'd have to stretch it event
what are the things that I want start a
class or kind of jumping around a little
bit in Chapter we're dealing with a
different cultural matrix than
anglo-america and when I say
anglo-america I mean you know the United
States and Canada which were not
completely dominated by my English
speakers but we're pretty much dominated
by them and which as we've seen in our
story Catholics were a minority and
sometimes an oppressed minority with it
eventually they become part of the
mainstream we've already gone over all
of that story what's different in the
rest of the Americas actually the bulk
of the Americans right because we're
other than this sort of little
english-speaking fringe at the top most
of the Americas are Spanish speaking or
Brazilian Portuguese speaking overlaid
over a whole matrix of all sorts of
Native American languages and cultures
so what are the inheritances that are
coming what's relevant from from spanish
colonial days
cuz they do kick the spam shop pretty
pretty early in the story we're just
changing you know who's in charge
doesn't always change the culture so
what was the dominant religion yeah so
the Catholic Church dominant religion
oftentimes that were there were clashes
between we've talked about this before
between representatives in the catholic
church and state authorities as matter
of fact Jesuits actually down in
Paraguay managed to raise a mercenary
army to fight against both the
Portuguese and the Spanish who are
horribly oppressing the Native Americans
down there what else what else is
important to keep in mind today that the
Spaniards just come in and build a bunch
of churches and everybody said all right
we're all Catholic is that the way it
works when you when you conquer somebody
think about some of our recent conquests
you know the United States is great at
taking over territories we don't seem to
be so great and nobody is actually at
changing territories that we take over
have we fundamentally changed the
culture the situation of some of the
countries that we've you know occupied
recently minor ways right we change the
government's yeah
source extractions and they didn't have
a lot of Spaniard 70 countries yeah so
what's the what's the impact of that
they were able to retain more of their
Genesis culture than say the united
states where there was a lot of the
simulation yeah we're just pushing them
out completely so Native American
cultures let's just use the word adapt
and there is some you know just complete
destruction in some places but there is
a lot of sort of adaptation and we use
the word fusion at the same time from
Spain quite a few of these people bring
a number of what we can call folk
religion customs and institutions lot of
you know a sort of over simplistic view
on the relationship between official
Catholicism and that is folk religion
that gets practice would be well the
official Catholicism comes from the
Spanish and on the full Catholicism from
Native Americans but really it's not
quite so so simple as that a lot of
Spaniards are bringing some of these
peasant customs from from Europe as well
similar to what was going on in rural
France or Italy or in southern Italy
another thing that's really important to
keep in mind is what your book calls
kind of ambivalence
church state relations it would be
tempting to say well you know in
Catholic countries the Catholic Church
runs the show it's the official religion
they're all subject to the Pope but if
you actually look at the history of how
things went quite often you have church
and state at odds with each other and
representing different classes of
society representing different interests
later on there's all these revolutions
durometer they kick the Spaniards out by
having all these these revolutions and
the church you know was not always on
the what was felt to be the right side
so there could be you know quite a bit
of animosity against the church as a
matter of fact when we think of
secularism some of the government's that
we're talking about for example in
Mexico in the 1900s were intensely
secular or intensely anti-clerical air
there against the practice of religion
they suppress it in some some cases so
this is all stuff to sort of you don't
put into the big picture thing now your
book that talks about each of these
groups in turn spends most of its time
on Mexicans admittedly and it says the
cultural social religious experience of
Mexican immigrants have brought with
them it's very different than other
Catholics for these sorts of reasons and
it talks about the inability of the
church and the state to nurture and an
indigenous leadership it was always sort
of top-down it wasn't very participatory
so what's the result of all this this is
a profound national ambivalence about
organized catholicism the one-handed
remained part of the fabric of national
life it's hard to think of Mexico
without in a concrete way without
thinking about Catholicism despite
opposition from the government
inteligencia on the other hand many
ordinary practitioners found themselves
unable to identify completely with what
remained sort of an alien imposed
religion there's also an emergence of a
folk religion that sort of coexists with
the formal structures and teaching of
the church it book gives some examples
of this full religion the Virgin of
Guadalupe how many never seemed like an
image of the Virgin of Guadalupe if you
again did look it up a month's worth
worth checking out there's a whole long
story there about Juan Diego and about
you know how this manifested itself the
real importance of the story is that
this is a way in which the the
underclass the ones who've been
conquered can sort of reincorporate
Catholic imagery and make it their own
this is one of the interesting things
about Catholicism and Eastern Orthodoxy
so really you know Christianity it goes
back to the early church and all these
sort of traditions is that you've got
you know our lady of this Our Lady of
that our lady of this why does that
occur well because it allows people to
have a sort of local expression of how
they how they view important figures now
your book talks about some other
examples of this as well about faith
healing about these votive images and
then it talks about some rituals and one
of the rituals that's that's
particularly easy to relate to i think
in part because so much attached
kincaid to it in media in the last 10
years is a quinceanera so what is it
what does the kids in air is supposed to
be so just a extra bash that Mexican
kids get they have you know a lot of a
lot of white girls have started doing
kinson eres sort of like a lot of non
Jewish kids actually do bar and bat
mitzvahs 10 subset worth an ox Jews
quite a bit but that happens what is it
supposed to be about sweet 15 so you get
the yeah maybe you get the carb you
can't drive it yet yeah yeah so remember
I we've talked a number of points about
rituals and their importance and one of
the key changes in time is going from
being a child to being an adult now
notice some of the the aspects of it
that sometimes get left out there's a
vow that's taken a vow of chastity until
marriage so it's a reaffirmation they've
done it is traditional setting religious
religious values your book also talks
about these these Lafe eternities these
penitential Brotherhood's that occurred
as well I'm going to skip over the
discussion about how how you know
immigration took place in the United
States one thing that your book does
talk about is that so they're been in a
certain sense to ethnic Catholicism's in
the United States you have these sort of
Americanizing let's take the Germans the
Italians the Polish make them you know
make them all part of one thing usually
this massive spanish-speaking
immigration into the United States and
they didn't really fuse that well
together until really from the 1960s on
and they start to pay attention to the
fact that they need some representation
there's a bishops commission for the
spanish-speaking a Catholic organization
aimed at the concerns of Hispanics this
is pretty important demographically
because they're one of the few
ethnicities the few traditional Catholic
ethnicities that still is growing in the
United States so that's where a lot of
church growth is going to be occurring
your book then starts talking about
about Puerto Rico and it points out one
major difference between Puerto Rico and
all the other places we're talking about
is actually part of the United States in
some sense right there's should be a
state is it a territory should have
remain in territory whatever you know
how are you you parse that out one of
the really important up shots of that
usually when we think about immigration
you move from here where you're a
citizen or a resident over here and you
become part of this nation here or Rican
immigration can go back and forth just
like say Texan immigration if we want to
consider Texans some taxes I will see to
consider themselves we're going to talk
about themselves as having a distinct
ethnicity you can look at it the same
way they go somewhere else they come
back but in this case we're playing with
small islands so it's much more
homogeneous that that experience is
rather than one of the largest states of
the nation so your book talks about some
of the differences in terms of the
ethnic mix but one of the more important
points is that during that most of the
colonial period Puerto Rico is largely
isolated from the rest of Spanish Empire
it underwent something different by
becoming an
in territory you have these Protestant
missionaries coming in trying to carry
out Americanization so although
Catholics like it says they're an
overwhelming majority of the island's
population a tradition of folk religion
an alienation from American church
leadership and highly independent
culture have worked against any strong
official church influence then they talk
about Cuba why did Cuba become important
it makes sense that you know Puerto
Ricans would emigrate to the United
States because they get to Ford easily
Mexican immigration was driven in some
you know part by agricultural migrant
workers but that very quickly developed
into all these outposts in towns the
town that I grew up in in Wisconsin
Waukesha actually had you know about
one-third of the population was was
Mexican recent immigrants which are very
few or they've been there for a long
time it was one of those sort of health
post towns you might become why do the
humans wind up here yeah they're
refugees yeah and that refugees from
from one because that's what really
changes the tenor their wealthier
classes like yeah now why did the
wealthier people the taxes got two hind
said well to hell with this like some
other people do yet social dream began
to take away property and assets rich
people yeah I mean Cuba was a hardcore
communist regime that was actually
trying to export revolution everywhere
else they were involved in Nicaragua
they will then go over to Africa and by
proxy wars they were serious about this
so a lot of the upper class the upper
middle class they leave Cuba and they
bring along with them you know whatever
wealth they can and they bring a lot of
them not only did you know sort of their
religion their customs but also a kind
of conservativism that goes along with
being from the property classes
your book talks about the importance of
a little havana in miami and dave county
and why that's so central so they said
the anti-communist motivation for this
endear these newcomers to the American
government because we were heavily
anti-communist at the time and the
Catholic Church in a way not experienced
by these other immigrants the results
has been a creation of a politically and
economically powerful on Club sort
centered around da county middle class
politically conservative supportive of
institutional Catholicism the Cubans of
South Florida share a little in common
with their fellow Latinos other than the
Spanish language and a formal attachment
to the Catholic Church so we already
have a considerable diversity in the
story here now how do we wrap this story
up your book brings up some really
interesting recent developments that we
should probably it's not an inheritance
from Spanish Catholicism it's something
fairly recent the Catholic Church is not
the only game in town in Latin America
or a South America the way that you
could have said that it was a hundred
years ago who else has come in who else
is starting to take a stake other than
people just becoming secular insects you
know forget religion forget the church
yeah I mean not not to the extent that
this this other group thinking about
what's up yeah and we're thinking about
Protestantism it's going to be mostly
very conservative groups quite a lot a
Pentecostal Protestants it's not that
the mainline Protestants who are growing
because they're not going anywhere
actually they're kind of their numbers
are just sort of shrinking away there's
some real demographic problems but
within Latin America and South America
there are a lot of evangelicals and a
lot of Pentecostals that are curing a
mission work and have them for several
generations that's having an effect on
spanish-speaking people in America in
you know the United States itself on the
religious landscape there so you can
find quite a few you know if you go
around two to spanish-speaking
neighborhoods you'll generally find
Catholic churches and then you'll also
find some are these as well yeah now
they will have a causal main center it's
the Catholic Church as it's because of
different sub tabs right next to it is a
pasta church I very often jokes i can
get Porsha Kristen posture to get ah
because you can't it's hard to get an
annulment and yeah